>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Applause ]
>> Roswell Encina: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm Roswell Encina, the
Chief Communications Officer
for the Library of Congress.
And welcome to the
Library of Awesome.
I'm not sure if you can tell,
I'm completely nerding out here,
and it doesn't end
there, you know, so.
If you're feeling awesome,
I need all of you to do
that big Wonder Woman pose.
I know many of you have
seen the movie already,
and I know for 40 years, you've been
watching our special guest tonight.
So I mean, I was not
the only person,
I'm clearly not the only
person that was twirling
around when I was a kid, thinking
I was going to turn into, well,
you know, to somebody wonderful.
And I know somebody
here who did it a lot.
So we want to thank you again
for participating here today.
It's a big deal that we
have our special guest here,
and it's a big deal that our
collection is on display.
If you didn't know,
the Library has one
of the largest comic book
collections in the world.
So if you haven't seen it yet,
we have this amazing pop-up exhibit
called the Library of Awesome,
where you'll see a lot
of number one comics,
including the first time
Wonder Woman appeared
in Sensation Comics by DC.
So it's truly a treat to see.
Also, if it's your first time at
the Library, please, you know,
feast your eyes to, you know, to
our treasures and the ceiling and,
you know, Instagram it
like crazy because we love
to see our pictures
all over the place.
Also, I mean, if you're
having fun now,
there's more fun events
coming to the library.
In a couple of weeks, in mid-July,
we're starting this first ever
outdoor summer film series.
It starts the second Thursday
of July and it will run
for six consecutive Thursdays.
It's going to be amazing movies that
you'll remember growing up with,
like "Ferris Bueller," "Top
Gun," "Raiders of the Lost Ark,"
and a whole lot more so please make
sure you have your lawn chairs ready
and we're going to have a great
time this summer at the library.
Now let's talk about
what's happening here today.
We want to thank all the sponsors
and all the donors who
make this possible.
We can't do what we do without,
of course, without Congress and,
of course, our special donors
that make all these
amazing programs happen.
But let's talk about
Lynda Carter, shall we.
So for 40-something years, I think,
you know, when she first appeared
on TV, I think all of us
have identified one person
as Wonder Woman.
So when you think of Wonder
Woman, you think of her.
So in the past 75 years,
Wonder Woman, you know,
she's looking great for being 75.
And we've got a little clip for you
to show you how she
changed through the years.
>> Lynda Carter: I'm delighted to be
here with you at the United Nations,
to celebrate Wonder Woman
being named Honorary Ambassador
for the empowerment
of women and girls.
As you know, I have some
familiarity with Wonder Woman,
and I couldn't think of a
more perfect role for her.
More than 40 years ago, I had
the honor of being cast --
more than 40 years ago,
more than 40 years ago.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
I was cast as Wonder
Woman by Warner Brothers.
This was a momentous
thing for, at the time,
there were very few women holding
their own shows in television.
They didn't think a woman
could hold a television show.
We started getting
letters and phone calls.
I started hearing stories.
This miracle of an idea that came
from a 48-year-old woman
named Elizabeth started
to have an influence in some
girls' and women's lives.
That was when Wonder
Woman became flesh.
This idea became a reality.
The she became we.
In some magical and mystical way,
there lies within each
of us Wonder Woman.
She is real.
She lives and she breathes.
I know this because she lives in
me and she lives in the stories
that these women tell
me day in and day out.
I see it in the eyes
that dance before me.
I see it in the letters
and in the stories.
I read it on social media.
I see it in the tears that
fall from the eyes of the women
who say it saved them from some --
it inspired them from some
awful thing that they endured
because they saw -- they saw that
they could do something great.
You see, women really
know who they are.
We can be smart and beautiful and
strong and wise and kind and brave.
We believe in fair play and fair
pay and playing by the rules.
We build families and communities.
And, yes, we stand by our
men, as they stand beside us.
Wonder Woman helps bring out the
inner-strength every woman has.
We are all inclusive,
that is who women are.
We are stronger together.
We are half the world.
We have a voice.
We are the mothers of all mankind.
Your mothers and sisters
and daughters
and grandmothers and
great grandmothers.
We are black and brown and
white and red and yellow.
We are tall and short
and thick and thin.
We are blondes and brunettes and
gingers and salt and peppers.
All you women of all colors,
all you children out there,
never forget Wonder
Woman lives inside you.
You can be anything.
I see these beautiful faces.
Learn. Know.
Be everything that you dream.
[ Applause ]
>> Roswell Encina: Ladies and
gentlemen, your Wonder Woman,
the 14th Librarian of Congress,
and the one and only, Lynda Carter.
[ Wonder Woman Theme Song ]
>> Carla Hayden: Welcome
to the Library of Congress.
This crowd is wonderful.
There's also an overflow room too.
How does this make you feel,
Ms. Carter, after 40 years?
>> Lynda Carter: Lynda,
please, Lynda.
Can I call you Carla?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh,
yes, definitely.
>> Lynda Carter: Or do I
have to call you doctor?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, no, no, no, no.
Madame Librarian.
>> Lynda Carter: Madame.
You know, it's really interesting
that after all these years,
that Wonder Woman has come full
circle and she's still so relevant.
That speech that you saw was given
at the UN and it was for women
and girls across the world.
And it was about the
idea of Wonder Woman.
When I said Wonder Woman is real,
it's the idea of Wonder
Woman that is real.
Because she does live in us.
It is the idea of that piece of us
when maybe no one believes in us
or we've been bullied or someone
thinks we are not tall enough
or pretty enough or good enough
or smart enough or enough, enough.
Or we have obstacles to overcome.
Or we live in a nation that
wants to hide our faces.
Or in an area that does
not have good education.
Or the skin we live in is
not an easy color to live
in in our neighborhood
or in our country.
I had a singer, one of my
singers, who is an amazing person,
said to me recently, she said, you
know, Lynda, I can't change this.
And living inside this skin
just became harder for me.
What do you say to that?
I say, I fight every day with you.
I say, I fight every day with you to
help educate, to help you realize.
You know, I'm an old girl now, but
I will never and until my dying day,
I will never stop fighting
for the idea of Wonder Woman,
the idea of intellect and strength.
Intellect and courage.
Intellect, what this
library gives us shows us.
What Dr. Carla Hayden is able
to offer in a digitized world.
At your fingertips,
a resource so rich,
so rich that you can
access it at any time.
That's what I hope for all of you.
That's what I hope if
my life means anything.
And who knows, poof,
we can go anytime.
If my life means anything, it's that
I give you the gift of curiosity
about yourself, about
the world around you,
about tapping into your
own intellect and courage.
That's how I feel about this.
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
[ Applause ]
So Lynda, I'm ready to
put on costume and go
out and do something, okay.
I don't know about you,
but that's what it means.
And even though -- and she's
celebrating her 75th birthday.
>> Lynda Carter: I'm not 75.
>> Carla Hayden: No, no, no.
The comic Wonder Woman
started in 1941.
Did you have any trepidation
when they said,
would you like to embody
Wonder Woman, in the '70s?
>> Lynda Carter: Nope.
>> Carla Hayden: You
said, I'm ready?
>> Lynda Carter.
Oh, no. You have to
understand the time now.
I was in Hollywood during a time
where there were no
women in television.
They did not think, first of all,
that a woman could hold a series.
They did not think that women
would tune in to watch an hour long
with a woman as the lead.
They also said, oh,
women are just going
to hate you, so just get ready.
>> Audience: Love you.
>> Lynda Carter: The
only other woman
on the set was a script supervisor,
which is basically the
secretary of the set.
There were -- the stunt
person was a man.
The first time I got on the set
and this guy had chest
hairs coming out the top.
Two bullets here.
Kind of walking like this.
I said -- he said, oh,
the camera's going to be
so far away, you'll never tell.
I said, I think this and
this, you're going to tell.
And I started, we started,
that show started,
the Stunt Woman's Association.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, great.
>> Lynda Carter: Women have to be
doubled by women from that point on.
And, you know, so this latest
fantastic momentous Wonder Woman is
directed by my good
friend Patty Jenkins.
She's a spitfire, oh my god, she's
amazing, and so is Gal Gadot.
So if you haven't seen
it, go see it.
>> Carla Hayden: In fact.
>> Lynda Carter: I didn't
answer your question.
Yes, when I got the part.
>> Carla Hayden: You were ready.
>> Lynda Carter: Okay, I was ready.
I knew what I wanted
to with the character.
I knew that if you didn't want to
be her friend, you either wanted
to be her or be her best friend.
And any guy that looked at
me and was with some girl,
I'd bop him upside the
head and say, get a grip.
>> Carla Hayden: Well,
I have to tell you
that director Patty Jenkins -- see,
we've got a lot of energy up here.
Because Patty Jenkins tweeted
this week a note from a person
who works at a kindergarten.
And she talked about the
impact that Wonder Woman had
on her kindergarten class.
And I just wanted to share
with everyone part of this.
A boy who was obsessed with
Iron Man had asked his parents
for a new Wonder Woman lunch box.
And Ms. Jenkins says, one little
girl said, when I grow up,
I want to speak hundreds
of languages like Dianex.
And another little girl had
her parents revamp her Beauty
and the Beast birthday party in
three days because she simply had
to have a Wonder Woman party.
And that's the impact.
And the note ended from Ms. Jenkins,
consider this your friendly reminder
that if this movie completely
changed the way these girls
and boys thought about
themselves and the world in a week,
imagine what the next
generation will achieve
if we give them more
movies like Wonder Woman.
What do you think?
>> Lynda Carter: I told Patty
that I was not going to see any --
we've spoken since the day after
it was announced that she was going
to direct this film,
we spoke the next day.
And we have become great,
great, great friends.
And I was very free with my
own ideas not about her film
but about the essence
of the character.
I never spoke to the
Gal about her character
because it's just not something
you do with one actress to another.
But Gal and I were so in
sync about this character,
I told her that I did not want to
-- I did not watch any trailers.
I did not read any of her
interviews about her process.
I only spoke to her directly.
I wanted to go to the premier,
which she invited me to personally.
I wanted to go to the
premier uncluttered.
And so I went with my
family, my grown children
and my husband to the premier.
And my heart was pounding.
And I was taken because the essence
of who that character is for so many
of us and for so long -- there's
a goodness, there's a heart.
It's about something.
It's about who we are as
people, as against the violence.
It's about defending what's right.
It's about being momma
bears, you know.
It's about those things
that we hold so dear.
And so this is great.
>> Carla Hayden: So did
you think about the fact
that you would inspire
generations of girls and boys
as you were really
fighting on the set
and making sure things were
going the way you really thought
they should?
But did you know or
even have a sense?
>> Lynda Carter: I
really did believe I had
to fight for a lot of things.
They tried to steer me --
they didn't think I was --
they thought I was too
sweet in the beginning.
And so they tried to
get me to be more,
you know, assertive with my stuff.
And a couple of those
episodes are real stinkers.
They were like, I can't watch them.
But when I kind of stuck to my
guns and just really wanted to --
you know, it's like,
this is who she is.
You know, you're born tall,
you can't make yourself short.
You know, it's just who you are.
You're born with what you're
born with and this are --
these are the cards you're
dealt and those are her cards.
And, you know, this is who we
are as we talked about backstage.
Whatever that is and whatever
age we are is what we are.
I like being a woman.
I like looking good, you know.
Do I like being older?
Well.
>> Carla Hayden: It's
growing on you.
>> Lynda Carter: I guess so.
I can't change it.
So I might as well embrace it.
You know, it is what it is.
And it's not exploitation, you know.
It is we're going to do what we do,
wear the dangly earrings
or not, you know.
If you like to work
and serve, great.
It's just who we are.
And we're not competing -- we're
certainly not competing against men.
We love our guys.
We are so thankful.
I'm so thankful for
the men in my life
that have helped me on this journey.
I embrace every single one of you.
I embrace every single one of
you who have stood by my side,
who have helped me when I
was down and I needed a --
you know, when I went
back to singing --
someone stole all my
music and all my stuff.
I was going back on stage and
my son -- I said [crying sound].
My son, you know, six foot five.
Mom, look at me.
[crying sound] If you go out there
and mess it up, we're still going
to love you, so, you
know, things like that.
I mean, you know, these
guys that support us --
I'm tired of them being
marginalized.
They're not feminists.
We own feminism, you know, we
women own feminism, it's ours.
You guys are not feminists.
You support us and we support
you and come along for the ride.
>> Carla Hayden: Now, we
mentioned the new Wonder Woman
and it's the number
one movie everywhere.
How that make you feel
when you thought, wow,
this is -- it lives again.
>> Lynda Carter: I told Patty that
-- before I saw the movie, I said,
this movie is going to kill,
this movie is going to be great.
She was nervous, you know.
There's -- she just made the
best movie she could make,
and that's all we can do.
Is we go out there and we do
the best damn job we can do.
And then the rest of it
is just the rest of it.
There are many elements
that we cannot control.
So she just put every
effort into it.
And she -- you know,
we talked an awful lot.
And she's brilliant.
She's a brilliant director.
You know, women can't
make action movies
and women don't go to action movies.
So, you know, boom, boom, boom.
And I said, this is
going to be great.
I said, this movie is going to
gross over a billion dollars.
There was silence on the other
end of the text, just silence.
And then after the first
week, the thing came in,
I said, what did I tell you.
And she went, yeah, maybe.
So it's already done like a
half a billion or $600 million.
By the time it's over, it will be --
which is good, because you want it.
You want people to
six and seven times.
And you want it, because it
just gives her more opportunity
to do more things.
Because I'm sure she didn't get paid
nearly what other directors have
been paid for similar kinds of
things, but that's okay, you know.
>> Carla Hayden: I
think she will now.
And if by chance they
asked you about appearing
in a sequel, would you consider it?
>> Lynda Carter: You know, she
asked me to do a cameo in this.
And she was in England, and
I was doing my concerts.
I went back to singing, it's
really how I started, is a singer.
And I was a jazz at Lincoln Center
and I was at the Kennedy Center.
And this year I'm finishing
up a new album.
So at that time, I just -- we
couldn't fit -- I couldn't --
we couldn't get it,
our timing, together.
And so this next time, if she writes
me a decent part, I might do it.
>> Carla Hayden: I think she will.
Because you have been busy
with your singing career.
You mentioned that.
And I don't know if a
lot of people realize
that you had a singing career before
and now you have a
new album coming out.
>> Lynda Carter: I
do, I have a new album
and it's really kind of eclectic.
I have quite a few original songs,
which I've been writing a long time.
But this past year,
we were nominated
for best original music
for a video game.
And guess what else?
The Library of Congress
is into video games.
Did you know that?
I mean, this is very
cool stuff, comic books
and video games, I mean, who knew.
And I do want to say
one thing, you know,
we're talking about Wonder Woman,
which is all fine and good.
But I had the great opportunity to
meet the 13th Librarian of Congress.
>> Carla Hayden: Dr. Billington.
>> Lynda Carter: Dr. Billington.
We were at a state dinner
and I sat next to him.
And when I realized who he was --
his life's work was digitizing,
beginning the immense work
of digitizing this library.
And how he explained it was it's
not just putting things online,
it is taking the original
work, not copies --
which is what you see
everywhere else,
is the copies of the
copies of the copies.
They're quite degraded by the time
you get to try to decipher anything.
So this was high-quality
digitizing of the original work.
And I was just -- for a person with
ADD, which I have -- could you tell?
It is just a source -- I went
into the Abigail Adams' letters,
and then, of course, there's
the little ole blue things.
And you go oh, I want
to see what that is.
Then you go over here and you go
over here you and you go over here.
And pretty soon I'm over to Abraham
Lincoln and then I'm over here
and then I'm over in Civil
War and then I'm over --
you know, it's like,
oh, my, it was just --
it is just such a treasure
trove of interesting --
of learning almost anything that
you could possibly want to know.
And seeing these documents
so clearly and paintings
and architecture and
anything that you -- anything.
And video games and comic books.
And you can look up Lynda Carter.
>> Carla Hayden: And
things are going to come up.
And that's why we call it
the Library of Awesome.
And we're building on that
legacy, Dr. Billington
and even the other Librarians
of Congress since 1802.
And it's just carrying the baton.
So we're glad you're here to help.
>> Lynda Carter: There have
only been 14, in the history
of the Library, only
14 Librarians, only 14.
>> Carla Hayden: And one woman.
So you can imagine how excited I was
to say, oh, Wonder Woman is coming?
Oh, sure.
>> Lynda Carter.
I have to say that what is
interesting about this is
that this is just -- I
mean, we are half the world.
As I said, we are half the world.
We are the mothers of all mankind.
Hello. This is about -- if
you're thinking of a family,
and you're thinking
-- well, you know,
we all agree that raising a family,
you really want to have two parents,
you want to have a
mother and father.
You want to have a father
and a father and a mother
and a mother, whatever it is.
But you want to have
coparenting and you want
to have the yin and the yang.
Why is it that we think
that's not purposeful
and important in our government?
It's a supportive and another
point of view, you know.
But women I think are much
less about hierarchy and more
about community in general.
That may be an overstatement.
But we don't ask how big is it.
I couldn't help myself.
>> Carla Hayden: Lynda.
>> Lynda Carter: I couldn't help it.
>> Carla Hayden: I think it's
time for question and answers.
Because I've had the
great honor and pleasure.
>> Lynda Carter: I know, I get
myself in trouble all the time.
>> Carla Hayden: It's
okay, you're Wonder Woman.
But I know that I've had the
opportunity to speak with you
and ask you some questions.
And there's just one before I
open it up and let everybody else.
Have you had -- I know you've
had down times in your life.
>> Lynda Carter: Oh, yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: Was there
something that you said to yourself?
Or how did you channel something to
say, I'm going to just keep going?
>> Lynda Carter: People
look at my life --
I was talking to my niece
who's in the audience.
People look at my life and they
say, oh, you know, she's had it all.
It's not the truth.
It's not where any of us are.
It's not what has happened
to any of us.
Yeah, I've dealt with some really
rough times in my early childhood,
in my middle childhood,
in my teenage years,
in my early adult life.
And worked for every
dime I've ever had.
Graduated high school.
Never went to college.
And I had to make a decision --
I actually got a scholarship,
an academic scholarship, to
Arizona State University.
But I also got an offer to sing
on the road for $600 a week.
Work at a pizza parlor to earn
my way, you know, or, you know --
I went the singing on the road.
And was the girl singer in the band.
And making these decisions
all along the way,
where you can go a
lot of different ways.
And I was pretty clear
on what I wanted to do.
It wasn't easy.
But there were a lot
harder times than that,
where you think everything is --
everything is down,
down, down on you.
And the world is crashing
in on your soul.
And I think the most
important thing I learned is
that I didn't have to do it alone.
I thought I did.
I thought I was just -- my
family broke up early in my life.
And I just kind of, you
know, was out there.
And I never -- I didn't go asking
for help for advice and help.
And you need to do that.
You need to ask your
teachers for instruction
if you're not following your,
you know, you get your homework.
Sometimes your children are
not doing their homework
because they don't
know how to do it.
They don't know how to
organize themselves.
Sometimes that's the reason.
Both my children had
learning disabilities.
They had genius IQs, but
they fell off the map,
one in math and one in reading.
I was able to figure that
out when they were very small
and got them some extra help.
Because they were so
frustrated and they felt stupid.
And I'm sure they got that from me,
the ADD bit or the whatever it was.
And they're both graduated law
school now and very successful.
But we had to retrain their
brains to do a certain thing.
But getting through it
is part of it, you guys.
That's part of it, is step one
foot in front of the other.
Stepping through it helps
to train your brain on how
to do the next step and
how you do the next step.
And I figured if this doesn't work,
then this will, and if this doesn't,
then this will, and if this
doesn't, then this will,
if this doesn't, then this will.
And ask for help when you need it.
And I learned that lesson,
and I've been in recovery,
by the way, for 20 years.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: I'm telling
you, we're going to be fired up
and ready to go after this.
This is something.
>> Lynda Carter: And it's a very
shameful thing, you know, to --
that's a shameful thing
to come to terms with.
I can do anything, how
can that get me, you know.
How could something
like that get me?
I didn't even drink till
my mid-20s, you know.
It was just the genetic components
in my body just, you know --
as soon as I started drinking
to get rid of feelings, boom.
And you feel so, so, so ashamed.
I don't talk about that much,
but I'm not afraid to
talk about it either.
You know, that's part
of being a grown-up.
>> Carla Hayden: It's also
part of being Wonder Woman.
>> Lynda Carter: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: Because what
you have just said and as I said,
we'll be fired up and ready
to go, is that everybody has
that spirit and that Wonder Woman.
And you have inspired so
many people for so long.
And we're just so pleased you
could be here with us today.
I know I'm going to really --
well, I shouldn't say this.
>> Lynda Carter: What?
Kick butt next week?
You're wonderful.
>> Carla Hayden: So
thank you so much.
>> Lynda Carter: And you know what,
I like that you wear flats, yeah.
I mean, they're little
kitten heels, I like those.
>> Carla Hayden: Kitten
heels, that's enough.
>> Lynda Carter: Yeah,
I've got my kitten heels
in the bag, I'm putting them on.
>> Carla Hayden: Well,
I had to step it
up with you being here,
you must know.
Had to do it.
So I know and I've been taking
over the whole conversation.
>> Lynda Carter: They told me
this is going to be 15 minutes.
>> Carla Hayden: See.
>> Lynda Carter: I
knew they were lying.
>> Carla Hayden: So
we have some people
that are really anxious
to ask some questions.
And we have two people, one on
both aisles, with the microphone.
>> I have to gain my
composer right now,
because I'm extremely
excited to be here.
I just have a comment to tell you.
My son passed away two years ago.
He was a Batman fanatic.
Graduated high school.
And I obviously am a
Wonder Woman fanatic.
And the last memory
that I have of him --
like you said, it brings you
strength that you gave me
that -- is I went to Starbucks.
And you know Starbucks, you
can be whoever you want to be.
So one day I'm Lynda.
One day I'm Diana.
And a lot of times,
I'm Wonder Woman.
And we went into Starbucks
and I had to use the restroom.
And I said -- I ordered his drink
and I ordered my drink, and I said,
Wonder Woman and Batman's
drink are coming.
And he was like, are
you serious, mom?
I'm like, yeah.
So when I got out of the
restroom, he had both of our drinks
and it was Wonder Woman and Batman
and it's one of the memories
and the pictures that I have in
our shadowbox that I made for him.
And I just wanted to tell
you, thank you so much
from the bottom of my heart.
I love you so, so much.
I traveled far to be here
just to be this close to you.
And you inspire me.
You inspire my niece,
my family back home.
And I just I want to tell you.
>> Lynda Carter: Oh, come here.
[ Applause ]
>> Is this working?
Yes. I have a two-part question.
First part is lighthearted.
I know you're an avid rower.
And I was wondering if you have been
invisible boat, because I've looked
for you and I can't find you.
>> Lynda Carter: I have not
been rowing this year yet.
But I belong to the Potomac
Boat Club and Thompson's.
so I gave my faster rowing
boat to the girls that are
in the Olympic rowing group.
They're rowing for --
practicing for the Olympics.
It's a single.
And anyway, it was too fast for me.
And I have my MAAS at Thompson's.
And as a matter-of-fact, I'm
going to get back on the river.
>> Yay.
>> Lynda Carter: Yeah.
It's called sculling
for those of you --
you know, it's that
really cool looking thing,
you know, you see in the Olympics.
It's very long and sleek.
And it's tippy, so if you do it
wrong, you boop right in the water.
>> So the second part
is, you look amazing.
So I'm wondering besides rowing
what you do to look so great?
>> Lynda Carter: Thank you.
Oh, I love you.
>> Carla Hayden: I think
we have another one.
>> Lynda Carter: I work
on it all the time.
You have no idea the
pressure, from my daughter.
Mom, why aren't you working out?
Hi.
>> Hi.
>> Lynda Carter: My daughter the
lawyer who's studying for the bar.
I said, are you in the bar
or studying for the bar?
>> She's probably both.
So hi, my name Ada.
I work across the street this year.
So in my normal job, I work
for the Department of Defense,
where I get to travel all over
helping people and the like so
that we can live a better lifestyle.
But part of it was traveling to
Iraq and Afghanistan and Jordan.
And I get to interact with women
who don't have the same
opportunities that we do here.
And I wear Wonder Woman
paraphernalia everywhere go.
>> Lynda Carter: You're
in the military?
>> No. They have a
height/weight requirement.
No. But in every country I
went, the women would come to me
and on the side say, I love Wonder
Woman, I want to be Wonder Woman.
And just thank you, because I always
wanted to be Wonder Woman too.
And to them, I was helping
them to be Wonder Woman.
So thank you.
>> Lynda Carter: You
know, there's --
I really do enjoy hearing the
stories, and I always have.
Many actresses or actors, they
want to divorce themselves
from a role because,
you know, we are actors,
we really aren't the
people that we play.
But I knew very early
on that, you know,
that this character is much
more than me certainly.
And to try to divorce
myself from the experiences
that other people have of
the character is silly.
So truthfully -- and my
family experiences it as well.
The stories that I hear from
people are always so much --
it's so much fun for me to hear and
to look at the glimmer in the eyes
of parents who tell me about
their children or people who tell
about their own experiences,
about feelings that they have
about themselves, or
the little plaques
that someone has given
them for their work.
Wonder Woman works here.
The symbolism about overcoming
things, you know, tragedies
or difficulties or the
admiration that someone has
for a certain woman, this is
all part of the sisterhood.
It's all part of the
idea of Wonder Woman.
And it's you, it's you and me.
It's you and me and Patty and Gal.
It's all of us.
And that is where some people
miss the boat on this character.
Yes, it's comic book.
I mean, we're not stupid.
But there is something deeper.
There is something more about this
-- it's not an ideal of a woman,
it's about her intellect.
It's about her character.
And that's what lives in us.
And gave voice to.
>> Carla Hayden: We have
time for one more question.
>> So I want to thank you so much
for your career and
your inspiration.
Growing up with you was awesome.
And I know your ethnic
heritage is Latino?
>> Lynda Carter: Uh-huh.
>> And I have my son's
Wonder Woman doll.
I took it back when he got older.
But how did growing up
Latino influence your life?
>> Lynda Carter: I was --
the question is about
growing up in a Latino family.
My grandmother came over
as an infant from Mexico.
And it was a very rich heritage.
Those of you who know any kind of
ethnic family, that there's a lot
of food and music and
interactions and all of that.
That's what it meant to me.
And it was a lot of fighting, a lot
of, you know, a lot of tamale making
and menudo making and
tortilla making.
And it was really wonderful
and my memories are very
rich in that regard.
I wish that my own children
had had some of that --
which they didn't because
we lived on the East Coast.
But I'm still in touch with many
of my cousins over the years.
And, you know, I have a
simpatico, I have an understanding
of the immigrant experience.
And I have an understanding
of being with my cousins.
And my mother came
from a family of 10.
And in those days in these mining
towns where my grandmother was
from -- her first husband died in
and the second had darker skin.
And so the children that
came after had darker skin.
And so the cousins and that,
so they had darker skin.
And we would be together,
and I experienced this racism
and this hatred of
others, the other.
And it was so confusing to me.
It was so unfair.
It was -- my grandmother had
asked me to take something,
return something, at the store.
And I said, why doesn't he do it?
And she would say, because
they won't take it from him.
I would take it back and
they would take it from me.
But they wouldn't take the return
from the darker skinned cousin.
And, you know, it hurts
you in a place that --
you know, it hurts
you in some raw place
that unless you've experienced
it, you don't understand.
Now, personally, did I experience
-- my children are Jewish.
So how far -- how many steps
removed are we from the pogroms
of Europe and, you know, people
yanking people off the streets
like is happening with
ISIS right now.
It's scary stuff.
So anyway, that is my
Latino experience and most
of it is absolutely brilliant
and I loved it, I loved --
that's what I take from it is
a great amount of understanding
and love for hard-working
immigrant families.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Well, I know
they told you 15 minutes,
and we have kept you a lot longer.
>> Lynda Carter: They
never said 15 minutes,
I was just giving you a hard time.
>> Carla Hayden: But before we end,
we just wanted to give you something
that we hope that you will know
comes from us with deep gratitude.
>> Lynda Carter: Don't I get
to give you something first?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh,
well, now, that's good.
That, oh, and it's behind the TV.
>> Lynda Carter: And
where's the other thing?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, there's more?
>> Lynda Carter: Yeah.
Where is the?
>> Carla Hayden: We better go
get some more stuff on our side.
Oh, my goodness.
>> Lynda Carter: All right, this
is -- where's my little note?
Wait, here it is, right here.
I'll show them.
This is an original issue of
Wonder Woman 77, Number One.
It's the original Number One issue.
>> Carla Hayden: And everyone
is seeing me accept this
for the Library, right?
>> Lynda Carter: And this
is an original illustration
by the artist Cat Skaggs, one
of the contributing artists
of the comic book series.
She created this piece of art
specifically for this event.
And it's one-of-a-kind and
it will not be reproduced
from the DC Comic War.
I want it.
>> Carla Hayden: You do?
[ Applause ]
Don't worry, you won't
see this in my office.
Boy. There's more?
>> Lynda Carter: This is
very cool, this is so cool,
you just cannot believe
how cool this is.
From the director Patty Jenkins.
To Dr. Hayden and friends
of the Library of Congress,
on behalf of all of us who made this
film, Warner Brothers and DC Comics,
we are so incredibly
honored to have a copy
of our script presented here today.
Both comic books superheroes
and the art form of cinema,
for all our uniquely successful
American -- American --
phenomenas that can at times
symbolize the best the United States
of America has to offer.
With this film, we aspired to
live up to the highest hopes
and ideals of both art forms.
So it is a particular honor
to have this housed here among
so many other great
treasures of our great nation.
I truly wish that I could be
there to stand side-by-side
with the great ambassador
of all things Wonder Woman.
But we are all there inspirit
and wish you great success
in your celebration of such
a unique and powerful medium
of the American arts, with
gratitude Patty Jenkins.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, my God.
>> Lynda Carter: The
original Wonder Woman script.
>> Carla Hayden: This is something.
>> Lynda Carter: Isn't that great?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, I'm sorry.
>> Lynda Carter: And it
truly is a thrill for --
when I first contacted them
-- Patty wanted to be here.
When I first contacted her to
do this, they were so thrilled
because of this great institution.
And every one of you, take this,
take this time, take this adventure,
take this with you and share
it with friends and go online
and become a part -- I
ask you personally --
to become a part of this family
of the Library of Congress,
because it is for you, it is for
our nation, it is the greatest gift
to honor your curiosity
for the ages.
And there is no other library
of its kind in the world.
Truly, truly there is no other
library of its kind in the world.
And its steward is the first
woman, the first woman of color,
the first person of color,
our wonderful Carla Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Well, the gifts
you have given us are indescribable,
and we just.
>> Lynda Carter: It is so cool.
>> Carla Hayden: We just
wanted to give you something.
This is a copy of the first
appearance of Wonder Woman
from Sensation Comics, and this is
in the Library's collection
and it's on display.
But we wanted you to
have this for yourself.
And it says, in deep appreciation,
presented to Lynda Carter with --
I can't even say how much
we appreciate you being here
and giving all of us inspiration.
We really, really thank you.
But I'm telling you.
>> Lynda Carter: We had fun.
>> Carla Hayden: We had fun.
And you should know that my "Wonder
Woman works here" sign on my desk,
I'm putting it on the door.
>> Lynda Carter: Oh, do.
>> Carla Hayden: Thank all of you.
We really appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Please
visit the exhibit.
The Library of Awesome
is here through tomorrow.
And we see are going to see, maybe
we can put the script on display.
So we'd love for you to see
it, so we're going to do that.
Thank all of you.
>> Lynda Carter: Remain good
friends of this library for the rest
of your lives, all of you.
Donate 5 cents, $5, $1.
>> Carla Hayden: Whatever you can.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.